[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm QB HD here and
one of the new pieces of hardware we got
at WWDC this year was this new iPad pro
now it looks obviously really similar in
pretty much every way to previous iPads
so you know may or may not be worth it
some minor improvements in here so I
asked on snapchat which you guys wanted
to know and believe it or not a lot of
you actually did want to see a review of
the new ten and a half inch iPad so
that's what we're doing so I've been
using it for a little bit a little more
than a week now and my previous tablet
of choice for when I did use a tablet
was the old twelve point nine inch huge
iPad pro this one makes it look huge but
I didn't really use it that often I use
it occasionally for watching videos and
general media consumption nothing too
crazy like that but this tablet has me
using tablets again a lot more often so
this is everything you need to know
about this new iPad pro so first of all
you've seen an iPad before you're
already familiar with the way an iPad
pro looks all-metal rectangular body
pretty exceptionally well built you can
see the antenna lines for the cellular
version up top and the ten and a half
inch display is slightly bigger but in a
similar footprint to the old nine point
seven inch iPad pro so it just has some
thinner side bezels now which I really
appreciate
overall it's a pretty solid but also
very light weight tablet to hold in the
hand so it's comfortable which is good
because you're gonna be holding it in
your hands a lot so what is new well
number one is inside is a pretty big
spec bump an iPad was already pretty
powerful but now you might have seen
these new headlines that the new iPad
pro is almost as powerful as a macbook
pro in a way that's kind of true it's
benchmarking really high in Geekbench
thanks to the new a 10x fusion ship
which has a 12 core GPU and is very very
powerful and capable it also bumped up
to four gigs of ram and just through
daily use I haven't come across any apps
or any experiences really that truly
pushed this new iPad pro to its limits
this thing crushes everything you throw
at it and I've played a variety of games
mess with productivity apps and gone
with them for long periods of time open
and this I've had barely brief to sweat
it really only just gets a little bit
warm and that's it the most impressive
part is actually how many apps it keeps
in memory and for how long like there
was more than one instance where I went
back through the multitasking UI
and found an app that was open yesterday
and tapped to open it and it was right
there where I left off which is pretty
dope so a 10x Fusion chip is a monster
plus four gigs of RAM is great and now
also 64 gigs of storage is the baseline
so that's a pretty solid spec bump if
you asked me the battery is about the
same apple claims 10 hours again I found
that to be conservative but pretty
accurate usually good for about two full
days of use often more though because
standby time is so good
I just wish iPads had quick charging
that's one thing that I feel like they
are kind of missing from the hardware
lightning wish it was USB C but not
expecting it so whatever but these
things charged kind of slow for a huge
battery like this so I wish they had
quick charging will be a lot more
convenient and then the camera yes
technically the camera on the back got a
big upgrade as well it's now running the
same 12 megapixel F 1.8 camera system as
the new iPhone 7 which doesn't mean I
had endorsed using it as your main
camera or anything but it's now super
overkill on the quality department for
some new features of support like
document scanning where recognizes text
and 3d surfaces and can scan documents
into the Notes app super accurately and
easily if you want to use the camera for
other things sure I get it it'll be an
awesome FaceTime camera it'll take 4k
videos with optical image stabilization
like it's an amazing camera it's the
best camera in a tablet but you just
won't see me using it any time soon
now the speakers in this tablet still
pretty good actually great because
they're the best speakers in any tablet
also as the quad speakers this has them
on all four sides so if you're gaming or
if you're watching a video or listening
to music the entire thing kind of
vibrates as this echo chamber and if you
put it on a table the table starts
vibrating it's loud it's crisp it's
clear great speakers also but the
biggest upgrade and the absolute most
impressive new feature of this iPad pro
is the new display so this screen is
better in every way possible it's
brighter you know up to 600 nits max
brightness and it has that anti-glare
coating and everything so it's more
visible and bright environments it
supports the wide P three color gamut
now so overall it can produce more vivid
bright colors and it's still the same
high resolution as before so 264 pixels
per inch beyond 1440p resolution but the
real killer is what Apple calls promo
and they didn't have to name it or
wherever but essentially the new iPad
display is now capable of a refresh rate
up to a hundred and twenty Hertz unlike
every other app will display on every
device ever which is going up to sixty
Hertz so the native speed of everything
that's happening on the display is now
60 frames per second instead of thirty
frames per second and you can definitely
tell so even in this 30 frames per
second video which can't fully do it
justice you can see how responsive iPad
is it's literally twice as close to
one-to-one movement with your finger or
the stylus as has ever been before and
it's awesome that the GPU keeps up with
everything and pretty much never drops
any frames because this adds a whole
layer of butter to the top of the OS you
honestly have to go to an Apple store or
like borrow someone's and try it for
yourself you have to see it to notice it
but once you do I guarantee you'll
notice it and then promotion also means
that it can dynamically switch the
refresh rate to go back down lower when
you're doing slower moving tasks like
maybe reading a book scrolling through a
webpage something slower looking through
photos but you won't really notice
because as soon as you start scrolling
quickly again or as soon as you hit that
home button and start swiping it's right
back to 120 Hertz so this is awesome I
really enjoyed using it and it did make
a really big difference in my iPad usage
experience all the in-app experiences
are faster all the between app
experiences are faster and I really hope
this comes to the next iPhone but that
in a nutshell is the new iPad pro it's
not necessarily any more Pro of an iPad
than previous ones it still runs the
same OS still has just better specs so
it's kind of like I'm Mac Pro versus
iMac just better so it's funny with a
lot of these videos where it ends up
just being a speck bump and I'm
reviewing a device that's clearly a
speck bump from last year the question
is usually well is it enough of a speck
bump to justify getting it or would you
kind of fade away to the competition
that's making bigger leagues forward but
it turns out with this tablet there
really isn't anything close in terms of
competition you might remember my last
video about tablets which was our
tablets dead and the honest answer is if
it's not an iPad it kind of is I don't
get me wrong there are some two-in-ones
and some convertibles not really pure
tablets but those things are better at
getting work done and better for
productivity things with actual physical
keyboards and
like that but as far as just a pure
tablet goes great battery life really
great display best camera in any tablet
best speakers I would say in any tablet
arguably best build quality in any
tablet best performance in any tablet so
this thing is a really complete package
so they have it iPad pro if you don't
already have an iPad probably a good
time to get one if you do already have
an iPad know that this is a really solid
spec bump and if that's what you're
looking for then this will fill that
void that's it thanks for watching talk
to guys in the next one peace
[Music]